studying here and I saw this place I'm
like oh my god this is awesome I have to
go here and buy some holm admission the
process they let me in and I came here
and then I decided to do an other
masters just like I say here longer
graduated had a kid she came here and
now you invited me back so so glad to be
here I love this place as you can tell
for lots of good reason what I'm gonna
do today is I'm gonna walk you through
my journey and building first off maybe
a minority the time I'll talk about
building blue Chi the acquisition by
Oracle and how that went they don't talk
about building vasya in the acquisition
by Cisco and then I'll talk about my
five rules of thumb for building a
business and for building a team and
we'll have a conversation here's the
goal don't wait till the end to ask
questions if you got questions ask them
if they flustered me I'll tell you I'll
answer them later so don't worry if I
make it through this whole thing without
a question I would have failed don't let
me fail so I will start now by talking
about kind of what was really
interesting about building blue Kai blue
Kai taught me one rule of starting
companies that I have I don't know if
it's a hundred percent true we could
have this debate but my belief is that
if you're gonna start a b2b company you
need to be an expert in the area you're
gonna disrupt and when I say expert I
mean to say that if you go out to a
handful of CEOs in that industry they
know you they know you by name because
when you're disrupting a b2b industry
the way decisions are made are quite
complex and they're unknown to you from
the outside everything seems simpler
from the outside and if your competitor
is started by a CEO who comes from in
the industry who has the rolodex of the
top CEOs who can make decisions much
faster who can learn much faster because
they don't make all the stupid mistakes
Outsiders do they will beat you
b2c companies are different because
everybody's a consumer and everybody can
self introspect and figure out things on
their own and you're usually creating
these new categories that didn't exist
and there is no expert who's more expert
than you so that's my idea of b2b I
could be wrong glad to debate it when I
started Blu Kai I was in the ad tech
industry I knew a huge number of the
buyers in the industry the ad agencies
publishers I knew them well they knew me
we were at conferences together on
panels together so on and when an
insight I had back then was that people
this was back in 2007 and there was this
huge growing digital ad business where
dollars were converting from the kind of
TV offline world onto digital very fast
and they were all being placed according
to contextual rules so if you're IBM you
bought The Wall Street Journal's
technology page to put an article
because the technology buyers read the
technology section of the Wall Street
Journal it was all place-based and we
had this idea that hey instead of
serving ads to a page
why don't we serve it to a person based
on the knowledge of the person those
insight number one insight number two
was there's 300 ad networks all these
publishers all competing to kill each
other in this ad ecosystem I didn't
believe I could build another ad company
that would be better than Google or like
at that time Yahoo and Facebook and I
didn't want to build a company that
would become number 4 who the heck wants
to do that I wanted to be number one so
I said why don't I build a company that
would supply the data for every ad
company out there and supply the data
technology and never compete in the
ecosystem with the ad players it's a
really good decision because what we did
is we started out got together a really
good team and we went up within the
first few months we signed up a eBay
Expedia cars.com
to supplies their entire real-time data
live and then I build an auction
marketplace and think about these
advertisers at that time everybody was
advertising them demographically and you
go up to them and say hey I have
real-time data from eBay Expedia every
search every click you can bid on in
real time the second they leave Expedia
and eBay you're gonna be able to show
them an American Airlines ad to someone
who just looked for a trip to Hawaii the
ad buyers loved it all the portals loved
it and we just started gaining liquidity
very fast and if you remember about 2007
2008 2009 the web started to become very
sticky you'd see a product ad and you'd
see it I really apologize for that so so
so that that kind of changed happen so
that was you know Wien landed our
commerce buyers we then landed our
strategic anchor tenants who are buying
the ads we started to get a lot of
liquidity and then the whole
programmatic ad space came in does
anybody here understand the ad ecosystem
or my sis am i speaking just really
weird not much okay cool anyway so we
started growing really quick and then a
really interesting thing happened
several years into building blue Kai we
were growing really fast
eBay gives me a call and basically says
hey we've decided we don't want our data
in an open marketplace we're just
looking for tech to manage our own data
could you license the tech we're gonna
pull out it was a really sad day for me
I thought because they were such a
dominant supplier of data for us and we
were the only source for that data I'm
like oh my god this is gonna kill my
marketplace so I made a decision at that
moment to never be over concentrated on
demand or supply by more than 10% and
that thinking allowed us to actually say
great let's just license our technology
for people where we do know buying or
selling of data we'll just give me all
the tech they need to run better data
driven marketing that forced us to open
up that model we did and that thing just
started taking off within a couple years
a dominant number of the top 30 brands
started selecting us as people like
Microsoft it was some of the key banks
hewlett-packard a good part of the top
30 companies in the u.s. selected us for
this private pay us license fees to
manage their own data and once they were
in there they realized they needed more
data so they went they bought it so a
build Center did the other business and
it took off we finally hit profitability
in year six and for some reason I really
can't tell you why within a two-week
period three CEOs of public companies
booked time with me cryptic not
explaining why I show up at lunch and
dinner and it's they want they want to
Wiress it was just odd talked to the
board they said yeah that sounds pretty
good if there's three at the same time
let's at least listen to them and a few
weeks later they acquired us so Oracle
became the winning bidder they acquired
us for 420 million this was back in
beginning of 2014 so interesting thing
happened a lot of times you go into a
company and you get acquired and they
ask you you know hey are you the golfing
CEO that you could just like hang out
and play golf and vest rest invest they
call it or what type are you I'm like no
no I only have an on button like if you
want me to play golf let me go you want
me to do something let me do something
so that was at the very beginning of the
process I met Larry Ellison the day
after the deal closed and he said look I
want you to build up this business it's
a really big business and I want you to
think beyond advertising and I want you
to tell me right now if you could buy
some companies what would you buy I'm
like you mean now he said yeah I said
can I have till next Monday so I came
back with a map and we just started
buying companies and we grew organically
and through acquisition and we hit 500
million in revenue really fast so it was
just a really fun journey it was just
nice to be able to like bounce ideas off
of Larry Olsen and see his pocket-book
versus the pocketbook I had access to so
that was a journey of voice at Oracle I
stayed there two and a half years
continued to build the company by the
time I left I had four CEOs reporting to
me on my executive team that's kind of a
interesting dynamic to try to run a team
with with that many people were used to
kind of running their own show some
magical reason it worked and we had fun
and we built it and I left and and one
of the CEOs of the company that acquired
it took over from there all right now
I'm going to move over to voice yeah I
left voice dia took a little bit time a
few months and I recruited a gentleman
who at the time was running the applied
AI at Facebook he reported to yon
laocoön I some people here know yon
laocoön any SS yeah one of the one of
the he what he won the Turing Award
so just great person in deep learning he
reported him and build deep text the
system that understands all your posts
in Facebook and because hun I was able
to recruit a bunch of other people I
pulled people a guy who was running
moonshots for LinkedIn I pulled people
out of Microsoft on Apple and that's
expensive by the way and so got all
these mo engineers we went off to build
what I'm about to talk about and I
realize needed funding and so I was
lucky to have Salesforce invest actually
right when I was starting the company
before we even launched I got this email
from Marc Benioff who I didn't know and
I booked out I'm like oh this is a
friend of mine pretending to be him it
can't be real I looked at it and it was
real and I met him and so Salesforce
invested and then after that a whole
bunch of other people Google jumped in
Cisco jumped in Microsoft jumped in so
let me tell you what we did so first
I'll ask you a question back in 2018 in
the summer there was a baby who said
their first words and it wasn't mom or
dad anyone want to guess what it was
yeah
Alexa old news by now so and that's Joe
Brady and there's this new generation of
people who have an expectation that they
can go and have a conversation with the
device and this is just taking off is
really interesting how it's gonna
transform what you expect in dealing
with the devices and we had this thesis
that there's gonna be a voice first
moment just like back in 2012 Zuckerberg
had his mobile first moment saying stop
designing for the web start first for
the mobile and think of the web second
we thought that there was gonna be a
moment in the enterprise this is what's
happening in the consumer space when the
enterprise space there will be a moment
when you start designing interfaces for
a voice conversation and the expectation
will be that the designers understand
you not you understand the interface so
you have to get into natural language
and make it easy for people to interact
so that was really what we were building
we wanted to build the voice first world
for a more productive work environment
we looked at meetings first because if
you look at meetings it's like 20 to 30
percent
of your time and if you're an executive
it's like 70% of your time and billions
of dollars are spent keeping people in
meetings and you repeat the same things
over and over and what we wanted to do
is just say we're gonna make them
productive and help you turn talk into
action you can walk into a meeting you
can make a few notes say you know this
is the action we agreed on this is the
decision we agreed on and it would be
carried forward shared with people and
then no longer be ephemeral so I'll show
to you what it looked like so I'll look
into my system here and we built an
enterprise voice assistant called Eva
Eva can basically read my calendar and
just show up in a meeting if there's any
sort of detail if it's a dial in or if
it's a WebEx link or zoom link or teams
meeting it'll just show up announce
itself show itself on the screen as this
little animated character that everybody
keeps confusing with Disney's Eva that
was the biggest question on our customer
support line OHS did you get permission
from Disney
it's Disney's isn't Eva I think it's Evo
or something like that in any case so it
just appears and it gives you closed
captioning so it's transcribing in real
time what you're saying and it's trying
to identify notes let me show you what
happens after a meeting so when a
meeting is done you get something that
you can navigate you see the concepts
right away that was discussed in the
meeting you can go straight to it so
immediately takes lead to the point that
anything was talked about or the
multiple points that was talked about
it's in lockstep with video so you can
see what was on the screen at the time
it's died rised meaning it's identified
who the speaker is and it's tagged it by
that speaker I'll digress for a second
this is one of the most interesting
design problems because in people's mind
they speak like Martin Luther King like
they're giving speeches actually most
normal meeting speech is more like
Anthony skaar Meucci and you
yeah it's totally sucks and when you see
it written as a document just as plain
text full screen it looks terrible it
looks unprofessional I've been on calls
with like really good execs who were
using the tool and they're like I
couldn't have said that and you click to
the audio and yeah they're repeating
themselves contradict themselves bad
grammar the whole thing so we have to
figure out a way how to show this and we
took a playbook from Facebook which is
they realized that when people were
doing comments if they were able to put
bubbles on it and make them think that
this is casual like text people would do
more of it and they wouldn't overthink
things and they got a lot more usage
that way so that's why we kind of
designed this UI that's you know easy to
navigate the text is like split up into
the speakers and and so on to make it
easy but let me show a few other things
so you can navigate it you see the
speaker you get speaker insights this
example Amy and I at Cisco had a
conversation with the Wall Street
Journal this was a journalist it shows
you speak time so in this case it was
Angus at the journal he spoke the most
and I can tell you if you're in PR and
you're talking to journalists you want
to get the journalists to talk you don't
to do all the talking that's what a
rookie does and so what we did has had a
successful meeting with them then
there's an edit shared capability we
basically step back and said if people
go to five hours of meetings they don't
want to read five hours of transcripts
right so they don't want it's more of a
summary and they're gonna want those key
items extract it and push to the
workflow
so here you can choose anything and
basically push it to any of these areas
Trello Salesforce teams all that kind of
stuff you can also set it up so it
automatically does this for you so for
example if you're in a meeting and you
can say okay Eva the action item here is
I should send a bottle of champagne to
everybody in the audience and charge my
competitor thanks Eva what happens is
that voice command gets captured it
creates an action item it goes into my
Trello board and actually puts that
action item in there don't worry I'm not
gonna send a champagne to anybody and
and you get these automated notes you
can also do things like translate to
other languages so you speak and the
audience can see it okay Eva switch
translation to spam
thanks Eva and what's gonna happen now
is the subtitles will switch to Spanish
as you can see the last subtitle
switched when I stop talking it'll it'll
move to another language there you go so
it's now in Spanish and this these
capabilities are now getting embedded
inside of WebEx in the next version
you'll have closed captioning and you
press and all of a sudden evil take
notes and then we're gonna start
embedding the workflow items so that as
you take these action items push it
through we also have capability of doing
automatically extracted action items
meaning you don't have to say you don't
invoke its name you can just say the
agenda here is I'm gonna demo this and
then I'm gonna open to questions and
because it knows that the word agenda is
interesting it's gonna capture that and
put it off or if I say the next step
here is for me to send you the contract
it'll do that and so on and so we have
to blend a lot of design on explicit
interactions with the AI and implicit
interactions this is one of the most
interesting design points everybody
wants to make it really easy to do the
implicit stuff just naturally this
figure out and do it for me those are
really hard one of the things we learned
from Google we actually talked to the
the team of Google about this is when
they first started what they did is they
said you're gonna put in keyword or two
in the search engine the very beginning
and I'm gonna show you ten links and we
think one of these ten links will be
useful look at the the humility of the
framing of the problem it wasn't you're
gonna say natural language and I'm going
to show you exactly the one link you
wanted right so it's an explicit
interaction where you tell it this is
what I want and it answers to you look
at Siri when they launched they started
out with this kind of really big
advertising with some of the best actors
and actresses setting your expectation
that you could have a full-on
conversation and how did you feel about
that it kind of sucked it didn't work as
well and it took time for them to get
better Alexa came in with the opposite
framing they're like hey here's this
thing just tell it turn on the lights or
set a timer play a song and I'll do it
and then over time it started growing
skills so look at the difference so we
tried to do the same thing blend hey
make it easy for people to explicitly
say okay Eva scheduled the next meeting
Monday at 10 a.m. thanks Eva right very
explicit and kind of do some implicit
things where it's just doing things in
the background and and this is just one
of the really interesting problems when
you're designing an AI product is
dealing with the fact that people have
unbounded expectations as consumers and
you got to bound it and over deliver on
that bounding so that you don't
disappoint them so anyway it's great
journey then let me go back to kind of
the the journey of building voice yeah
so we started voice en 2017 assembled
the team we launched in alpha in May
staying free we did our funding right at
the beginning as a seed round then we
did our beta launch in November and
because we started having some stats on
our beta launch that were really steep
and up into the right we got our series
a right after that that's when more
strategics came and I think Google and
Microsoft workday and Cisco all came in
that round the seed round was just
Salesforce and then what we did is we
recognized that a lot of people the
version we had would join your meetings
automatically and then give you a web
interface there was no mobile
interaction where you can just pull out
your mobile phone and drop it on the
table and talk in the context of there
being no meeting so we found this
company three people that were building
a mobile app and they were using kind of
off-the-shelf speech technology we had
invested in really good accurate speech
technology and so it was a good
complement to us so we acquired the
company and then what we did is we a few
months later we opened our paywall
there's a really scary moment for me
because I had no idea if any was gonna
pay for it you're really gonna pay the
extra dollar it's already paying you
know zoom and WebEx for the conference
system are they gonna pay an extra
amount we started converting right away
yes question you saved me by the way
thank you
what steps you took as the early stage
to prevent others from just everybody
was communist right at the early stage
I'll repeat the question did we do
anything at the early stage to prevent
people from copying us there were so
many copycats why was I comfortable with
that I had an amazing tech team in a
very hard problem space and I knew that
nailing the interaction with the
customer was so damn hard it was and
I'll and I'll talk a little about that
here's an interesting story before I
started the voice eeeh me and the CTO
and my co-founder who runs product we're
experimenting with this other idea that
I refuse to take funding for we had
built and an assistant that wasn't a
voice assistant it would read your
calendar your email and it learned very
quickly to do things like hey respond to
this email you forgot it hey this person
responds in 30 minutes you take four
days
don't double cancel this meeting you've
already cancelled before stuff like that
was a really cool tool why didn't I
start that company because exactly what
you're saying I realized that I would
not have a data advantage that Google
and Microsoft owned each half of the
world's email and calendar data and I as
a start-up would be competing to get
more and more data and all they had to
do is buy crappy competitor number 72
and they could still beat me because it
have more data so I didn't found that
company this company I found it because
I realized that 99.99% of all voice in
the enterprise's in the ether not stored
in a system of record so nobody has a
data advantage literally nobody so I
figured if we had the right algorithms
and we created the right user experience
we could get we could get ahead of
competitors and we had a lot of
competitors they didn't scare me I was
worried about it's actually the same
insight behind the folks started into it
when they started into it they said
they're not competing with other
creators of software for accounting
they're competing with a
paper-and-pencil so I was competing with
people who just took manual notes not a
bunch of startups who were trying to
solve a hard problem
and didn't necessarily have an advantage
so great question the only thing we
discovered to your question was there is
a new type of competitive advantage I
didn't think of before blook I had a
classic Network model meaning the more
data suppliers I had the more data
buyers wanted it which created liquidity
which made it easier for me to close the
next data buyer and that loop continued
that was a classic network model this
had a new type of network model I call
it a compounding competitive advantage
because if you could build AI that is
constantly training on this data it's
different all the everybody does AI says
their data is caught their models
concentrating the hard part is to
automate the entire loop of data
collection to algorithm creation to
making sure that you haven't created
more false positives or or change the
the profile of how the system works and
automatically deploying it every hour if
you can do that you're competing with
other AI companies who will ship new
algorithms every quarter so if you can
learn people's language models so you
walk into a meeting and you say new
acronym the system doesn't know it in an
hour later it knows and it updates the
language model it gets better and better
gets stickier for the consumer and they
stay with you and you get more data so
that kind of compounding competitive
advantage is really interesting in this
new breed of company all right so where
we've got the mobile company we hit the
paywall
people started paying our economics were
terrible we were advertising on Facebook
to get people to get to know Eva and the
conversion rates was just okay and then
for people who tried the freemium and
then there was a conversion rate for
people to try the to actually upgrade to
pay after 30 days and if you said no we
downgraded you to not the full
experience but at least you kept it free
and so we spent the next you know six to
nine months just optimizing every single
aspect of that funnel or economics
started to get better our conversion
started and get better and we started
closing a few enterprises then what
happened is its 2019 and Cisco comes to
us and says hey we want to embed Eva in
WebEx just as a partner deal we're like
okay they're like we'd
an accuracy test and you're really good
you're actually just a hair a bud ahead
of Google how'd you get there so he said
oh this is how our system works
essentially it's a cheating system let
me just say it right off it's called an
ensemble and the way the ensemble worked
is we built a bunch of our own engines
that did speech and then we plugged in a
external engine we tested IBM Microsoft
Google we selected Google and the
ensemble would take the answers out of
all these engines in real time and
assemble a better answer than any one of
them because it was a deep learning
layer that was trained how much it could
trust them it took the original audio
created its own model and it beat
everyone it was actually the performance
envelope of the best of them it took all
the best attributes any better so yeah
of course you're the most accurate a
little bit more expensive because we
have to compute that much more so cisco
came to us great and now that we know
you're cheating we're a little bit less
impressed so here's a challenge because
we don't want to like pay you and Google
right because your cost now absorbs
their cost and we have the security and
privacy concerns that now the data is
out there we want to control it we want
you to rip out Google and still beat
Google talk to my CEO and it's like oh
we sat down for a quarter and we just
focused on that goal and we did it we
actually created an engine that had no
external parties and it still beat
Google's engine at which point they were
incredibly impressed because they're a
small team instantly came up with an
offer to acquire us so at that point had
a really hard decision I'd taken around
20 million in funding done a series a so
didn't have a ton of dilution small team
30 people full-time and I had this
really interesting insight and that was
I was modeling myself after slack and
zoom now slack came into a world where
there already were things like HipChat
and so they're optimizing on an existing
model they didn't invent it they
optimized it and they created a viral
loop that was amazing and a really fun
and simple interface zoom same things
matter of fact Eric came from WebEx so
he just improved on a model that existed
except he took a consumer
approach making it really easy to be
viral to kind of grow to grow zoom so
both of those really good enterprise b2b
consume Erised viral models took
existing understood concepts and
optimized the funnel and virality we
were creating something fundamentally
new that people didn't understand they
didn't wake up in the morning and
understand what the heck is an
enterprise assistant is it Alexa is it
the transcriber I don't know
and we'd expose them to him like oh yeah
this is kind of cool but it was a little
missionary and it was early and so our
economics were getting better our growth
was very fast we were seven hundred
percent growth all that looked good but
I didn't see the enterprise's converting
that into big deals so I said okay I'm
gonna have to take probably another 50
million in funding in order to really
prove out the conversion from individual
user to enterprise and I honestly gave
it a 50% chance of succeeding meaning I
don't know like it's too early to tell
so then I would have taken seven minutes
70 million in funding on the odds of
flipping heads or tails like I know
about that so when they came in with a
good offer we were like okay we'll plug
it into WebEx we'll be able to hit 300
million users and you know I went from
zero to two to two and a half years and
it was a good acquisition with a good
return from the investors so anyway I
tell you that story because the first
company blew KY we went all the way to
profitability once six years a quarter's
for four on a 20 million this one was
two and a half years they cried hers for
125 million but very low dilution on our
part because we only had a series a so
sometimes you have to think through
these things someone might look at me
and say you should have rolled the die
you could have built a billion-dollar
company you didn't need the money
personally so just take the risk and I
kind of look at it it's like investors
are like the people I know personally if
I got to take your money I have to
believe in better than a 50% odd and so
that was my reasoning was I right I
don't know doesn't matter like I'm
having fun we're really psyched being
part of Cisco and are now part of a much
bigger set of users and continue to
innovate
okay I'm gonna switch and now talk about
my rules of building business
and so consider anytime you want to take
this in any other direction or if you
have any questions about voice eeeh or
the AI problem you're solving go ahead
and ask so first if you're gonna build a
business you have to start with a really
big problem you can't start with an area
that is too small because there's no way
that your original inception is gonna be
exactly right and require no change so
it might as well be a big problem space
so you give yourself a flexibility of
moving and changing so that's just a
rule number one it's all of interesting
big problems and if it's not big enough
don't rush step back and say what's a
bigger problem for me to solve that's
the first one the second one is really
focus on an awesome team go find people
that are better than you and have the
humility to believe they're better than
you this is the number one problem I
find with execs is the ego that prevents
them then people are better than them so
they will hire B players so that they
can stand tall or they'll hire an a
player and constrain the heck out of
them not given the freedom to execute so
go hire world-class people give an
example when we built voice eeeh like
you know I told you my co-founder came
out of Facebook this guy is like really
really well-known I mean he's just
really understands a problem he's
solving my next co-founder had run
product teams before he had it's a
product manager he ran product
management he had 85 people reporting to
him before he came in even though he was
he had no one reporting to him here he
had the experience set the guy who ran
sales ran enterprise sales for WebEx and
then built the sales team at blue jeans
so in the conferencing space you know so
everyone we recruited was really really
good so do that and be humble about
hiring just awesome people it seems
obvious but it is one of the important
things the next rule blue oceans anybody
read blue ocean strategies
so Lewisham strategies are really simple
an example of it as Southwest Airlines
came into an airline market you would
think is crowded though the way
long-haul flights at the time were lots
of competitors deregulation coming in it
was like up an ocean with red blood
because the sharks are attacking
everybody in it's just really hard
competitive market with a race to the
bottom just didn't look attractive
Southwest comes in and has this insight
and says I'm not competing with Airlines
anyone know who they thought they were
competing with any any takers yes
buses Southwest competing buses not
Airlines they did short hauls
and they created a new market space and
they grew and they grew and they grew
and that's kind of what blue ocean
strategy is about is finding a category
where you can kind of create a new form
of consumption and and blook I certainly
was that because we didn't compete with
that player as we created data
marketplaces ever new
so I find those really interesting the
polar bears everybody looks at polar
bears playing with like nice little cute
polar bears think they're cute what's it
interesting about polar bears is they
eat their children yeah ugly analogy I
know so that's what it feels like when
you're running a company and you run
into a business model that is so
disruptive to you you have to ask
yourself maybe I need to kill my own
model before my competitor does so
that's what happened with us when we
were a blue Kai eBay called and said hey
I want to you too soft or not your
marketplace and then I saw another
competitor have the same model and I'm
like they're gonna eat my lunch if they
give their softer and it gets adopted to
everybody people will use my marketplace
list
why don't I invest and I do that when we
did that the board was like dude that's
expensive like really you're starting
another business side to business within
12 months I remember they came to the
our last board meeting with with little
literally a crate of champagne and
outside the funny thing is I don't drink
but they didn't know that and so I
looked happy and so polar bears is all
about cannibalizing your own market if
you have to and not getting over
attached to the way you've done
your business the next thing I would say
about building a business is that I
think there's two models of finding
product market fit surfing and sculpting
so let me describe them and you can tell
me what-what you favor so sculpting is
basically you know the artist looks at a
block of material and sees in their
minds eye the beauty that they want to
create and then they go in there and
they creatively fetch out what that
masterpiece looks like so that's one way
to think about a startup a surfer
doesn't create they don't create the
waves they identify the waves and the
artistry is and how they ride it but
they're not fooled into thinking that
their wave creators so those are two
different models any preference what do
you guys think a good startup is yeah I
guess I lived with this that's my
opinion it doesn't have to be right when
you think about the way Apple created
kind of the iPod and stuff like that it
feels a little bit more like the
sculpting model but maybe not because
they saw out there a need they saw that
it was underserved that there were poor
interfaces so I don't have to be a
hundred percent right but it's just my
way of saying do more to read the way
the environment is moving the way
ecosystem is shifting and don't drink
your own kool-aid and thinking that
you're the generation or your generator
of that trend and the rest of the idiots
out there just have to get on board
again you know arrogant entrepreneurs
with something somehow think that that's
right last thing I already said this was
have a deep understanding of the buyer
ecosystem so the reason we were able to
do blue Kai and walk into the CEO of
Expedia and land it sounds like a
ridiculous deal back in 2007 to go to
him and say the CEO of Expedia was gonna
approve a deal where he hands his entire
real-time data asset to a start-up same
thing with eBay he sounds insane and the
reason we were able to pull that off is
we knew
how these folks thinks we gave them a
pitch that was so so simple we went up
to CEO Expedia daraa who now runs uber
basically went up to him and I said you
have a small advertising business he
said yeah I said do you believe in the
next few years you're gonna be the
number one advertising companies like no
not really
number two no I said how about this why
don't we make everybody an ad ecosystem
compete for travel dollars by bidding on
your data so every ad that gets served
gives you money it's like great how much
money would that make we had a
conversation back and forth while we
closed the deal and then we closed a
whole bunch after him you can't do that
if you're not from the ecosystem
understand their psychology have the
connections and have the credibility so
that when they're asking who's this
who's is dude asking for my data I kick
him out of my office those background
checks he knows who you are
çf already knows you so you have to be
from the ecosystem unless you're doing
b2c again my idea anybody want to
challenge that because yeah I don't be
right not from the ecosystem you said
your key must be better than more it's
more experienced than you and they are
100% right I agree with you it doesn't
have to be you your team has to have
someone at the top level it can't be
buried in but someone who's influencing
your strategy
who's going to meet with other people in
the ecosystem
who's recognized and who understands
them I agree definitely doesn't have to
be the CEO it helps if it's a CEO but if
they're a prominent remember your team
that's awesome - totally totally agree
cool so those are my rules for building
the business in terms of team building
I already covered the first one which is
be better than you hire people that are
better than you and I mean this meaning
the technologist should be a better
technologist the salesperson should be a
better salesperson the marketer should
be a better marketer that's what you
should be striving for and if you really
think you're just better than the mall
then Wow and there are a lot of people
like that egos are plentiful in the in
this world so empower and hold people
accountable this one seems obvious is
where I think everybody falls apart here
is an attack
six of it everybody thinks they're
holding a team accountable but then you
go speak to the team and they don't have
an agreed vision on what exactly are the
small number of goals three to five this
quarter so that they understand
everybody in the business from the CEO
to the very last person that company how
they contribute to those goals so we I
evolved this over time but generally
what I do before the beginning of every
quarter even in big business sights I
still do this I start out with before
the quarterly plan has developed I start
out about a month in advance with my own
vision of what I think needs to change
how that you could change what the goal
should be a then start week number one
go to my exec team and say this is what
I think you have one week go back to
your teams and you tell me what you
think it should be so I come week number
two I just do a readout they tell me
what the bottoms up vision is for what
changes we need to make what's important
what's not week number three we do all
the planning so that we end it with an
off-site and collectively decide what
the goals are week number four we come
up with a goals poster that basically
says these are the four goals or three
or five with precise measurements that
we can use and then every week that goal
posters put up in front my executive
team and we basically say where are you
here what help do you need and we keep
the focus on that and I get it it
definitely does the question was is
there a reason why that I don't hear
them first before I come up with mine
it's a really good question I thought a
lot about that and you want to have I
tend to be someone who cares a lot about
the vision and finding that a unifying
vision through the company energizes
everybody and if it doesn't come from
the top and you have more of a
democratic vision that's coming from
everybody it's easy to get off track and
what I'm talking about vision I'm
talking about real fundamentals so by me
spitting it out I'm able to set some
guardrails so people don't feel like
they're completely being rejected so if
somebody comes in and says hey I want us
to do sock puppets puppets it's a really
hard conversation conversation say no
but you you don't want to outright just
be cutting out the the ideas that that
are problematic so instead what you're
doing is you're saying here the bounds
and it's a wide bound your execution
boundary may only be like this but at
least by setting it here you're cutting
out the rest of the area where you're
just pretty sure we don't need to go
there you make a good point that that
might not be the right answer but if
you're doing this on a quarterly basis
with an execution mindset that you've
got to actually get this stuff done in
those 90 days you kind of want those
bounds to be tight the conversations you
want more open-ended are a little bit
longer turn like that horizon to horizon
three ideas where hey where do you want
to take this those can be completely out
and there you want kind of a little more
inbound now recognize that week two is
all inbound so I don't really constrain
people to say oh you said something I
didn't say most of the good stuff you
know pushes the edges but you make you
make a good point so in any case the
last thing is that you take your team
and now they take those goals and they
take it one level deeper all the way
down and execute and then you stand up
and from the company you give anyone
permission to say if I come as a CEO
with the real excitement about a new
idea that falls outside of these goals
you have permission to tell me if you
want me to execute that tell me which of
your goals you're going to drop and that
happens all the time I will come in and
say hey customer says this can we get it
out and my product guy who knows me
really well is like here it is which one
drops and you have a lot more discipline
in your execution as opposed to people
get excited about with CEO says then
they drop what they should be doing
because they think the CEO liked it you
get all this randomness so empower your
team to get stuff done now once you've
agreed on these goals you get the hell
out of their way all your job is to make
sure they have what they need to succeed
and you don't script them and how they
work because you've already agreed on
what let them figure out the how and if
and if they need to change in the next
what
quarter out balance team this one's an
area where people fall apart where
they'll get a very engineering mindset
but not someone who really understands
how to take you to go to market or
someone with a very good go to market
mindset doesn't understand the product
side they you need that balance I've
been amazed at how when you speak to set
of really good algorithm engineers they
will look down at the salespeople as if
they're stupid I'm just gonna say it
like that
like literally be able to talk about it
was it stupid and then you look at the
salespeople and they'll look at the
engineers like they're such geeks they
don't understand business they don't
understand like you have like all and
you don't want any one of those ways of
thinking to dominate you want all of its
come into play field where everybody can
bring their best and you want to foster
some sort of respect between these
people like you don't need your sales
person to code and you don't need your
coder to sell so on and so forth so you
want that balance and you want that
balance also in thinking like extroverts
introverts male-female culture you if
any any diversity to bring in the team
the team will be a better team next one
culture matters but there's no culture
in my opinion that's really like the
right culture like you got to figure out
the culture for you and you need to
figure it out early and roll it out at
Boise it was really simple we cared
about GSD get stuff done that was like a
dominant thing because in a startup you
need to move fast come up to ideas test
it and so on second one we cared about
was being data informed and so not the
highest paid executive in the room make
some decision the data and informs it
they doesn't drive the decision because
sometimes you need intuition too so that
was one we wanted team players I had
learned early on when I went to MIT
later came to Stanford this mindset of
the brilliant person is the one you
wanted a team and that's all that
matters and in my first 10 years of my
career was that my 10 just want to
surround myself with brilliant people
the problem is sometimes brilliant
people are not not more than
non brilliant people it's just it's just
some of them are and they're very
disruptive because they will prevent
good work from the people around them so
you want both you want people are really
competent but people who are what I call
multipliers that when you put them in a
group everyone around them works better
and so that was like one of
cultural thing I won't go through the
rest of our culture but that that was
what worked for my team if you're
developing something be thoughtful about
the culture because otherwise you'll
have a random culture which is just the
amalgamation of the character of the
founders it's not very thoughtful and
you'll have to figure it out later
and and you don't want to do that so
culture matters and the last one is over
communication of goals you heard me say
it before I put the same goal poster
every week in front of everybody
people then at the end of the quarter
get to look at me say how did we do
against these I can't be asked them
right I've attended I can't tell you how
big corporations I've seen where general
managers will get up and they'll show
this thing about how well the business
is doing and you have no idea what they
promised before so they're just
cherry-picking what metrics make them
look good like huge number of executives
play this game just show something up
into the right why are we looking at
juju beans going up fluid does that
matter what did you promise last week
right so over communicating the goals
gives you that sense of accountability
all right I'm pretty much rep rep two
minutes let me stop open for questions
yeah the question is how do you stay
focused we have this exciting AI
technology can fly in a lot of areas
it's a really important question that
you have to believe that the area are
focusing on has enough fruit right that
has enough room so you want to do this
more it kind of depth first once you've
chosen the right area go deep deep deep
to make sure you nail it then you can
nail the next adjacency the problem is
is if you're wrong about the area going
deep in you would have forgone the
ability to explore a breadth-first
approach to find that one area that's
going to just nail it so you have to
balance those two a little bit we stayed
our whole time here but we had a plan
that mirrored our cache that basically
said if we haven't nailed it by this
time and we're worried about cash we'll
start exploring so we can make sure to
give ourselves an opportunity to find
another area but we got lucky our area
just had enough growth good question
Oh last question
Oh
accents yeah really good question so
speech speech models have to cope of the
question was how do we handle action so
speech models have two aspects to them
the first one is an acoustic model and
the second one is a language model so
the kusik model will listen to your
speech in Turnitin to phonemes at least
in English and then the language model
takes phonemes and statistical language
models like how much words co-occur and
it basically says it's likely this word
and so the acoustic model is where you
need to be able to customize for accents
it's one of the huge problems in speech
and what we did is we would map
individual voices into an n-dimensional
space according to acoustic
characteristics and then what we do is
we'd find this speakers nearest set of
people in that space and bias the
answers of the engines to that that's
how you take care of essentially accents
with that we're gonna have to wrap it up
so please join me in thanking Omar